there's morphological consistency
phonetic consistency and then there's
orthographical optimality can you place
numbers on those like you can say this
language is 90 optimal orthographically
and at 50
morphologically consistent can you
actually Place numbers on them
yeah so let me give it right so for
example finish is considered an
extremely good uh orthography is
completely consistent enough you know uh
kind of aspects
um
some languages are like
Croatian for example
is a the orthography was created under
the principle right as you speak
so that has this consistency that
you can just uh you could you don't you
never make spelling mistakes you just
write as you speak
sorry which language was this like that
that sounds interesting
that's uh the the server it used to be
server operation now these are separate
languages but it still applies to it
Croatian it now Spanish which many
people are familiar with this is another
type of language where you know always
know how to read something you may you
may still make spelling mistakes
but you will never pronounce a written
word in a wrong way
so that's another type of consistency
the English doesn't have either of those
right you can
you as a native speaker will probably
make mistakes unless you have a spell
checker even though you know perfectly
well how to pronounce a word
and me as a second language learner of
English I will encounter words that I
just don't know how to pronounce right
so it is definitely a problem in English
but other languages are even more
difficult like the Japanese
orthographic system is even more
difficult than English
I'm curious if English stands out as
best or worse in Sun metric and if so
which for instance I heard that English
can convey a complex sentence second
best something like that and Mandarin is
first you can think of it as a simple
language as one that a child may just
come up with on their own and it goes
ooh and ah and the complexity of what
they can convey is small and so somehow
there's some way of measuring that I
don't know I don't know the the actual
terminology I just heard this and I
heard that English is actually pretty
great it's second in the world and
Chinese or sorry or Mandarin is best at
that but anyway the point is I just
heard this so what is English great ad
and not great at
yes so so English English and Chinese
have something in common which is that
they are analytic languages so
morphology in English is is very basic
compared to languages like Spanish or
polish
I mean in uh in Chinese is even more
simple basically there is no morphology
at all
so in that in that sense these
analytical languages uh reach some kind
of Maximum at some
within that particular condition
I I know that um
English is if you compare things written
in different languages
sometimes you see on products like 20
languages with the same message
the English text will probably be one of
the shortest ones
so I I think this is maybe something
you're referring to that
that it can actually
convey the same message
with fewer letters or fewer symbols
foreign